first the president's core supporters
put up with a lot from day to day we
don't need to be specific about that you
know exactly what we're talking about
starting with the tweets we won't go on
but the shortcomings this administration
are clear they're usually worth it
though for two reasons first the idea is
the president ran on are basically right
America first ought to be the operating
principle of every American
administration by definition
it's an American administration America
should be first but that's not the motto
of most administration's not even hardly
second the alternatives to what we have
now are scary and getting scarier the
Democratic Party is completely
irresponsible and increasingly
anti-american they prefer illegal aliens
to our middle class that's true and is
terrifying and someone needs to defend
the country from these people
Trump mostly does that so for these
reasons most of the president's
supporters have stuck by him no matter
what has happened and a lot has happened
but there's a limit to the tolerance
they will not tolerate and they
shouldn't have to tolerate by the way
betrayal on the core promises of his
campaign and it seems to be happening on
guns unfortunately a few days ago the
president called for raising the minimum
age for buying a gun to 21 by the way
that's four years after we let people
join the military they can join at 17
but he's saying you can't buy a gun
until you're 21 now nobody's even
arguing this will save actual lives
because there's no research that it will
it's propaganda and it's sneaky
propaganda by the way it's an
incremental step towards more gun
restrictions that's all it is and then
yesterday the president even further
than that he met with lawmakers to talk
gun control at the White House at that
meeting he went after Republicans who
want to defend the Second Amendment
suggesting they're puppets of the NRA at
one point the president said the
government should quote take the guns
first go through due process second now
I mean how honest do you want to be
imagine if Barack Obama had said that
just ignore due process and start
confiscating guns well bomb would have
been denounced as a dictator we would
have denounced him first trust me
Congress would be talking impeachment
right now someone be muttering about
secession well a media agreed with what
the president said yesterday so they've
underplayed it or they presents it as
just a little battle between the
president and the NRA but it's not about
the NRA it's not even about the
president it's about the Constitution
and the Constitution remains the same
who's in power that's the point of the
Constitution the Second Amendment
protects your rights to bear arms
doesn't say that obliquely or
metaphorically it says it explicitly and
the supreme court several times has
interpreted it that way
explicitly protecting your rights to
bear arms you can't lose that right or
any other right the right to worship
freely the right to say what you want
without due process period those rights
are what make us citizens and not mere
subjects of the powerful and the
president needs to be reminded of that
maybe we all do once in a while the
voters wanted that kind of government
they could have voted Democrat and
actually they still have a chance to
vote Democrat in the midterms which he
should keep in mind congressman Sean
Duffy is a Republican who represents the
state of Wisconsin congressman Jody
Arrington is a Republican representing
the state of Texas and they join us both
tonight congressman Arrington to you
first I mean if we just be honest for a
second because I think it puts it in
stark relief how would you have
responded if President Obama said well
we'll just take the guns and then we'll
deal with the due process question I
think more than disconcerting would be
an understatement we're talking about
our god-given fundamental right to
protect ourselves not just against bad
people but have been against bad
governments that's the context and so
yeah look this you mentioned a lot of
things this president has done right
America first he's strong on border
security he's strong sense and he's put
a constitutionalist in at the Supreme
Court has done a great job in that
regard but but this this one he's going
down that slippery slope that knee-jerk
reaction that we're accustomed to when
you have these mass shootings and I I
would pose President Obama and I would
oppose President Trump and any president
that negotiates away what is a
fundamental right and quite frankly it's
a right that if it were not exercised by
our founding Patriots we wouldn't have
the rest of our rights and we wouldn't
have our independence so this is a
serious serious issue so congressman
Duffy news coverage 24-hour news
coverage this basically is 24 hours of
attacking Trump and so we kind of pull
back from that because we want to offer
an alternative agree with Trump on a lot
there's a lot else going on we try to
cover that but I also think it's
important to remember that you know
nobody should be tied to a per
but instead two principals and so with
that in mind do you think it's worth
just reminding the president as we all
need to run it sometime that there are
deeper principles here than just kind of
winning the news cycle
all right there's deeper principles like
the Constitution and but you know I have
a part of the president for doing these
open you know rips with whether it's the
victims of the shooting or with
politicians whether it's on Doc or on
guns I think he gets high marks for that
but also I think he can say some things
that he might upon reflection regret and
I hope this is one of the things that he
actually does regret and what frustrates
me in this whole conversation Tucker is
the fact that the left wants to put a
new gun restriction and new gun laws in
place because they want to argue to the
American people that that's going to
keep us safer I think you and I based on
your intro and Jodi would agree those
new laws don't actually keep us safer I
look at I was a prosecutor for ten years
in northern Wisconsin in Ashland County
and if Nicholas Cruz had lived there
this shooting would have never happened
because my cops would have seen the
threats that had come in the tips that
had come in the fact that they'd been
called to his house and when Nicholas
cruised through his mom up against the
wall they would've arrested him they
would have thrown him in jail they would
have come to me and said we're gonna
have a bond hearing and we're gonna have
it as a condition of bond the fact that
he can't possess a firearm and then we
want you to prosecute him whether it's
for a battery or a disorderly conduct
with an enhancer that's a domestic
enhancer and in 1997 Bill Clinton signed
a law that if you're convicted of a
crime that's a domestic crime you can't
possess a firearm we would have gone
through that procedure and Nicholas Cruz
right have not possessed a firearm
because we have good law enforcement
good and good prosecutors I don't know
what happened in Florida but to add new
laws on top of laws that already aren't
enforced is idiotic well and especially
because I think congressman Arrington it
doesn't address the actual failures that
led to this tragedy in parkland Florida
why are we not having a national
conversation about why the Sheriff's
Department the FBI the school the
deputies on the scene all failed to
protect those kids well I think that's
right it was a failure to to identify
register and engage or respond and there
was failure at every level of government
and clearly there were some training
issues at the local level with respect
to active shooting
we need this we need to bone up on that
but we also have to secure our schools
and get serious about that and accept
the reality that this is a fallen world
and accept the reality that no matter
how many laws we have in place if
somebody is hell-bent on murder and
destruction they will stop at nothing
certainly not respect for a gun-free
zone to carry out their their dark
desires so the last line of defense
tucker is to make sure that our people
in our communities can defend themselves
their families and yes the students that
means that that we need to do more of
what Texas is doing in my opinion and
make sure that last line defense is that
teachers and coaches and administrators
are appropriately trained license and a
part of that security defends at school
so kind of Snuffy can talk for hours
about this we don't have much time at
all but what's your best guess for why
this is happening in the first place
what would drive in nineteen year old do
want to murder strangers listen I think
there's a whole bunch of issues that are
taking place outside of guns Tucker I
think our kids in America are angry
they're being raised in single-family
homes without fathers as a congressman
being away I know that our boys
specifically need fathers in the home
they're being overmedicated which you've
talked about we say they have attention
deficit disorder so we medicate them
instead of parent them we have violence
that comes from Hollywood we dehumanize
life in those video games and in those
movies and with abortion there's a whole
slew of issues that we have in America
that we didn't have 40 years ago and we
have to address the root cause of what's
bringing kids to be so angry and so
detached
listen cell phones Tucker these kids
they don't talk to each other anymore
they don't know how to interact with
people and because they're detached
because their phones and parents aren't
engaging them to draw them away from the
phone in the conversation they're
isolated that's a hard conversation to
have as you're sure to say I have a
political agenda to take away guns and
and that's where the left goes at CNN
instead of going let's talk about the
root cause the problem which is how
we're parenting and raising our kids
we've driven out faith and morality on a
call from the family that's all part of
the problem here of course it is and
you'll be mocked for saying that but
even the people mocking you on some
level know that you're absolutely right
they know you're right because you are
thank you both gentlemen congressman
thanks